[Music]
cloud9 selects blabber fish - I kind of
discarding around no I always gonna play
in the split out there on the screen
flip because I still hadn't been in
school I mean I was happy to see Niger
up to me I didn't expect to play for
them with their postseason hopes hanging
in the balance
cloud9 bring and another new piece to
the roster another rookie blabber starts
the day in the jungle she wants to
describe that either one of them is
stupid one of them is [ __ ]
I like the dialogue mid game for no
reason I get I just get impatient I'd
say you'll call me a point for the
player reapered actually said that to
meet their goals last year I mean
obviously it's like not nice to hear as
a player that there's a chance you're
either really good or you're just really
bad blabber suburban speed flash good
side set from zorbidor know whether it's
gonna be enough
but blabber still Dysport that's the
blabber aggression some of the reason
you submit is because he's going for
those plays
if one scene I'm like how would you rate
importance of the players importance of
the players you think blabber has just
been like the most important to me seems
like he's just being able to like
facilitate everyone
cloud9 waited six year and they will
hoist the trophy again for all five
players the first time in their career
the next is fall electric field the
killing flow and lap nine with the 2020
out yes bring wish coming to the split I
knew I had to have a strong performance
and I was trying really hard to make
sure I mean I would play well and not
limit came down coming off the play
against summer coming off this day I did
inspect you to MVP but it's nice quad
put it over the final rusev blabber they
have the follow-through not quite yet FB
I don't have it for the other anchor in
toward this four keys Bob bench kicks
back of the ward off nicely played by
blabbered blabber is North America's
best jungler and it's not even close and
his first full split as a starter the
young jungler helped cloud9 capture
their first LCS championship in six
years they will not stop it
cloud9 waited six year and they will
hoist the trophy again for all five
players the first time in their career
the next fall Blakely steals the killing
flow and flat
with the 20/20 out Fiat bring flesh but
blabber did more than win his first
championship
the guy was voted first team All Pro
jungler and league MVP hello everyone I
am here with the 2020 Springs Floyd
Honda MVP its blabber he's only just
become a starter and he's already taking
the league by storm
he was absolutely incredible don't let
him you know be humble okay I'm not
gonna let him do that he killed this
split he slaughtered every other jungler
it was absolutely groundbreaking and he
still has the highest win rate of any
player ever with the amount of games
that he's played but before he was the
league MVP
lapper was the MVPs understudy it was
unfortunate like I always thought Dennis
was super good to like having him above
me it was like I guess unfortunate for
me because there's no way I thought
there was no way that I'd play over him
because he was performing so well I mean
I MVP if spring was blabbers split last
summer belongs to spend scarin the
veterans starting John Willard led the
team to another Finals where they lost a
Team Liquid well they're looking for the
dive middling here I think ya know flash
on POA here comes round to bodyslam
flash gonna find that what if all they
could possibly need first blood picked
up wells van was popping off with the
main roster blabber was right there
behind him as a sub soaking it all up
entering the 2017 scouting grounds
tournament while still in high school
whatever didn't expect to get picked up
by a team when should I think of his
scouting grounds I was actually a bit
confused and I told them like I can't
play spring blah blah blah and they knew
that to Jack like send me an offer he
was like I want you and I was like sure
but it didn't take him long to find
success after he was given the green
light to compete scene 9 now on the
Nexus turrets in from last place to
knocking down the spring split champions
cloud9 man
have just found a roster that works from
there he slowly became cloud nine sixth
man while Spence Caron played most stage
games it wasn't unusual to see blabbers
sub in see Spence Caron is known as the
more conventional jungler while blabber
plays with a more aggressive style take
finally onto the stairs Fuji steps out
for a little too far forward he has his
ground up is gonna have to lances fight
and go stage so the fight on the other
side of the map licorice and darshan
going head-to-head it's reignover
not feeling good about this one there
goes darshan rain overs on the
stopwatches bio frost had not helped
they've already dropped to heap and
cloud 9 hold the trigger but not all of
glaber's plays turned out well sometimes
he'd go too far not knowing his own
limits many people considered him a
coin-flip player all mechanics no brain
my experience playing his lever did
actually not make me one play with him
at first
you actually quite the opposite I did
not want to let my team justify him our
thought he was coin flipping a little
too aggressive and sometimes an inter
but despite the risks of blabbers play
style it was also a possible wind
condition cloud 9 even tried to use
blabbers Popoff potential at world's
against tournament favorite g2 in
Griffin he's gonna have to flush away
and now he's flash list extra movement
speed flash good side set from soul but
I don't know whether it's gonna be
enough comes on
[Music]
but blabber still died sport that's the
blabber aggression some of the reason
you submit is because he's going for
those plays after spending almost two
years in Spence Karen shadow blabber
wanted to be in the spotlight
so this offseason cloud9 had to make a
decision but Emily wasn't sure if I'd be
starting um
I mean pretty much knew either me or
Dennis we're gonna leave I don't think
either of us wanted to split time
anymore we both felt like we should be
having the settings position I mean end
up working out for me instead I'm
starting here but it wasn't something I
went into the offseason thinking like
yeah I'm gonna stay on scene I'm blabber
came into the spring split with big
shoes to fill after all he was replacing
the reigning League MVP coming to this
but I knew I had to have a strong
performance and I was trying really hard
to make sure that I mean I would play
well to not let my team down coming off
of like sense cares summer I'm VP
performance so I really wanted to make
sure that I was playing well display too
I mean obviously I didn't expect to get
MVP but it's nice Lambert has become an
ace premier jungler keeping his super
aggressive play style just - those
random deaths I think I really developed
a lot as well as taking like toward the
end of last year was leadership role in
Academy just because I was one of the
veterans then and then I think this year
specifically I think I've just gotten a
lot better personally about I guess
planning on not killing myself
surrounded by equally talented teammates
who dominate their individual positions
blabber found the perfect team to take
him through fiery rookie to League MVP
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages